welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boston this is a breakdown of Marvel's
Loki season 1 episode 4 the Nexus event
so ahead of Loki season 2 we are doing a
Loki season one re-watch because we were
able to find even more details in Easter
eggs and we need to check it out with a
fresh perspective and figure out where I
can adopt my very own adorable little
Loki Gator the season two premiere of
Loki is days away but don't worry we're
going to continue this re-watch series
in between episodes one and two of
season two because I think the Loki
fandom needs to be reawakened before
they care enough to re-watch this but
don't worry we're gonna get to all of it
but this episode is especially important
to revisit because for episode 4 we just
finally saw a deleted scene in recent
days from this episode and there is a
crazy detail that connects this episode
to the next MCU film okay we opened this
episode back on Asgard shown from an
angle that we haven't seen before
because the camera swoops up from over
the mountains as this haunting music
plays
[Music]
so in the Thor films Asgard is always
shown from the bifrost bridge in the
front but here we see the back door of
the palace because this is Sylvie's
timeline and her beautifully Serene home
stands and stark contrast to the chaotic
apocalyptic event she's been hiding out
in but here she's still just a kid
played by Callie Fleming who is Judith
from The Walking Dead and she plays with
toys Dragon swoops towards the palace
the valkyrie flies over defeats the
driver
guess we see Valkyrie on a pegasus Thor
admitted Valkyrie was also his fan Crush
so of course this would be the toy that
she would most admire we see a dragon a
viking Longboat another one in the back
over by the seat and large wooden wolf
maybe Fenris whom we saw it hella side
in Thor Ragnarok but TVA Minutemen show
up and arrest Sylvie they are led by
then hunter rensslayer in her a23 helmet
which we mentioned before when it
appeared at the end of episode 2 is a
reference to Avengers 23 from 1965 the
first iconic appearance of Verona
rensslayer and at the time a huge detail
that Kang orokang variants was behind
all of this but also notice that they
enter from a door that they create
behind Sylvie which would explain why
she told Loki that she never sits with
her back to a door this moment was
really the start of all her traumatic
events in her life there's no real
explanation for her arrest other than
it's just for crimes against the sacred
timeline that she'll commit at some
point in her destined future but I like
to assume that he remains has been
controlling Sylvie's life in the
beginning so that she will one day end
up at a citadel this is really the first
Nexus moment to set her on the path that
he wanted for her and I think what feels
particularly cruel is the way this reset
charge erases her toys even that is so
mean Sylvia's brought into the TVA and
goes to the same process that Loki went
through as an adult it was scary and
intimidating even for that grown-up so
we really feel her fear and everything
that she's experiencing she sees another
variant who shouts no as his arm is
Twisted behind him and Sylvie yells out
for someone to help him this is a stark
contrast to adult Soviet pruning and
murdering anyone who gets in her way as
a kid unlike adult Loki she cares about
other people she clearly was not evil
she goes into the transcript room and
the guy doesn't yet have his cat or his
cat mug Sylvie's transcript of
everything that she's ever said is
significantly thinner than Loki's was
she has her temporal Aura scanned and
winces as it takes her photo with a
Flash and loud noise Sylvie's brought
before a judge but she Stomps on
rensslayer's boot and steals her temp
pad to get out of there she not only
realized what the temp pad was but also
figured out how to use it immediately so
she's obviously an extremely bright kid
remember last episode she told Loki that
unlike him she taught her herself magic
and this episode makes it clear that she
has been evading the TVA for years since
she was just a kid and remember as
Guardians and we think Frost Giants age
a lot slower so like Generations
Generations eons upon eons and maybe the
reason he remains chose this variant was
because she's even more resourceful than
all the other Loki's she was also young
enough when she was taken to remember
the warm safe home that she lost and I
think that makes her dangerous okay so
we cut to the present day and actually
this whole thing was really rensslayer's
memory this is guilt that she has been
carrying with her she's kind of like
Reginald Vel Johnson and die hard always
haunted by the time when she shot a kid
she walks out of the elevator doors to
see the timekeepers who are really just
smoking mirrors we learn at the end of
this episode there is literal smoke here
like when Dorothy meets the grand Wizard
of Oz and behind them is a glowing red
symbol that kind of looks like the runes
Agatha and Wanda use to Market magical
boundary and prevent others from casting
spells maybe this is how they keep
people from using magic inside the TVA
the way that they're dressed in the way
that they're displayed like that on the
wall is definitely Leonard to the three
most important people in the world and
Bill and Ted's Excellent Adventure they
were the futuristic Council who kept the
timeline on track and were played by
real life musicians Clarence Clemons
Bruce Springsteen's E Street Band Martha
Davis lead singer of the motels and fee
Wayville lead singer of The Tubes the
timekeepers are just more ridiculous
theater from he remains and his desire
to entertain himself rensslayer says do
you have any idea how
timeline stable the timekeepers are all
that stand between us and full-scale
Calamity yes this is more TBA propaganda
like the posters and the Miss Minutes
video designed to keep everyone
compliant in their mundane busy work
tasks on lamentis one Sylvie tells Loki
about the events we saw in the first
scene and that it took her a long time
to figure out how to hide from the TVA
and so that's where I grew up the ends
of a thousand worlds
now
that's where I'll die Mobius in a still
shaken looking Hunter B15 searched
through apocalyptic events for Loki and
Sylvie and that Chrono monitor screen
shows Wrightsville Pennsylvania January
6 1832 something about January 6's but
that was actually the year a bridge over
a river collapsed due to ice and
flooding next to that is Morag that's
the planet where Peter Quill recovered
the orb containing the Power Stone in
Guardians of the Galaxy Morag was
actually home to an advanced
civilization that was wiped out by
global warming catastrophe and that
originally for Guardians of the Galaxy
Peter Quill was actually going to go
scuba diving and that was going to be
what they had to do in Avengers end game
when they Revisited Morag like an
earlier time when it was still
underwater at the time Peter Quill
visits it at the beginning of the
Guardians The Waters at low tide and
geysering up and that's why he had to go
after the orbit that particular window
of time sakar is also on the screen
remember the trash planet from Ragnarok
and we also saw this on the screen at
the end of episode two also Alberta
Canada considered one of the riskier
provinces to live due to the frequent
floods and wildfires it's also the
birthplace of Wolverine later in the
scene when they spot the lamentis one
branch timeline the screen also show
those unidentified Planet then Barcelona
which we saw on the screen back in
episode 2 and then aladna a new detail
will be very recently spotted in a
different video on new rock stars but
this is a planet we're going to be
visiting the upcoming film the Marvels
this is where Carol Danvers has a
husband and Prince Jan it's a planet
where everyone speaks and rhymed music
lyrics but rumor has that they might
have trimmed that subplot down in
post-production also on the screen we
see Lima Peru we get this awesome point
of view shot from the planet as it gets
closer and closer to lamentis one
breaking apart and hurling chunks of
debris everywhere before we cut to Loki
and Sylvie serenely sitting in the midst
of that Devastation having accepted
their Fates Sylvie asks do you think
that what makes a lokia Loki
is the fact that we're destined to lose
we may lose
sometimes painfully but we don't die we
survive there's this idea of Destiny
versus Choice how much of this is being
written by he who remains we also see
the truth and Loki statement at the end
of this episode when it is revealed that
a whole bunch of Loki variants thought
dead actually survived in the void but
Sylvie sphere is also a lingering one
that Loki has struggled with in Avengers
a dying Coulson told Loki you're going
to lose
it's in your nature
you lack conviction in fact throughout
the MCU we've seen Loki both lose and
seemingly die only to survive many many
times Sylvie and Loki hold hands causing
a huge branch in the timeline the
titular Nexus event which allows the TVA
to get a temporal lock on them and swoop
into the last second before they're
obliterated so once again the Loki's
don't die they survive but if the edit
back to the TVA happens abruptly in this
episode it's actually because there was
a deleted scene from this moment that
just came out in the past week take a
look what happened on this Moon
I did what you asked me to do
my way perhaps
unconventional
what was sophisticated
not quite the uh
TVA way but I did it
and now you have her that's what
happened
I'm not your enemy
I am
oh
rest them both
Mobius
you have to trust me I don't
prune it
and get them back
but in the Final Cut I like that we
don't see Loki hold still be hostage
like this because it kinda undercuts the
honest connection that the two had just
had these two here share one last
meaningful glance before they're
separated and movies brings Loki to the
time theater 25 and sends him through a
door similar to the ones the TVA used
for time travel except it's red instead
of that orangey yellow red the same
color as that Rune down in the
timekeeper chamber maybe there's some
kind of connection there as that's
something that kind of controls the
barrier of how magic can be used in the
TBA now long time new Rockstar's viewers
know how much we use geology and how
long we've been using it for but if this
is your first time hearing about geology
get ready for Blockbuster quality
skincare on a student film budget
geology is a 23-time award-winning skin
hair and body care company recognized in
men's health Oprah daily hypebeast
birdie Esquire and GQ geology's products
are just a handful of powerful proven
ingredients that have been trusted by
dermatologists for decades geology can
help you fight acne reduce oiliness
prevent wrinkles combat dark or puffy
under eyes have smoother hydrated skin
and Target signs of aging everything you
need to keep your skin healthy no matter
how much you soak in the pool this
summer don't know where to start geology
can create a simple and effective skin
care or hair care routine for you all
you gotta do is take a quick 30 second
quiz right now if you use the code new
rockstars 100 geology will give you 100
off their award-winning skincare trial
set you'll also get an additional bonus
offer of up to 30 off one skin hair or
body products when you add it to your
trial it's truly a while to offer one of
the best they've ever given our audience
so click the link in the description or
go to
geolog.i.e
rockstars100 to get started Loki quickly
discovers that he is in a Time cell a
sort of prison that Loops a memory over
and over and over again kind of feels
like something out of an episode of
Black Mirror Jamie Alexander returns as
lady Sif you
as if you conniving craving pathetic
worm you did this what
I hope you know you deserve to be alone
and you always will be at this point JB
Alexander had last been seen in the MCU
and Thor the Dark World since the
actress had been filming the TV show
Blind Spot during Ragnarok now she did
appear in two episodes of Agents of
Shield and post Loki she shows up in
Thor love and thunder where she lost an
arm and then trains them as guardian
children in the ways of combat Loki
cutting siff's hair is actually from
Norse mythology in which Loki cut off
sif's hair as a prank and a make up for
it had the dwarves the sons of Vivaldi
make a headpiece out of gold to replace
siff's hair and that version Sif is
Thor's wife and since she was very proud
of her hair Thor was understandably
pissed at his brother adopted the sound
mix in this scene is just so good like
each time the loop restarts you can hear
this reset noise because it was just a
bit of fun
you and each time Sith punches him the
punch gets louder on each pass to convey
the pain level that Loki is experiencing
[Music]
in episode 100 B15 smacked him in the
face with a reset stick you're now
moving at 1 16 speed
feeling all that pain in real time which
is just another example of manipulating
time stretching it out to punish it to
make sure people feel every nerve ending
firing this whole experience has been
like a Purgatory for Loki with him
feeling pain over and over again until
he's ready to grow and move on Sophie
meanwhile is in time theater number 47
which could be a nod to Marvel what did
number 47 titled what if Loki found
Thor's hammer first in which Loki takes
Thor's hammer could be a bit of
foreshadowing for the post-credits scene
in which we will see one of the Loki
variants holding a variation of mjolnir
movies tells Hunter B15 you know we
brought in Cree Titans vampires why is
it the two orphan demigods are such a
pain in the ass ah Cree we've seen
before most notably in Captain Marvel
Titans obviously refers to the people of
Titan thanos's Homeworld but the mention
of vampires lays the groundwork for
blade which is supposed to be released
sometime during phase five but has had
several delays but it's just interesting
that the TVA has brought in both cree
and Titan's views I'm pretty sure we saw
those two warring races in the Miss
minutes animation video in episode one
but the scene with Loki and Mobi in the
interrogation room is just so good the
acting is perfect but also take a look
at the lighting throughout the overhead
lights shift downward so this room may
be part of one of those spiers that we
saw in the TVA exterior that rotates
past whatever the outside light source
is Loki tells Mobius that he and all the
TBA employees are variants so before
this you had a past maybe you had a
family a life
foreign
the camera stays on Owen Wilson the
whole time for this and he's got these
brilliant subtle reactions on his face
he has at least expected this is the
case but he's not ready to admit it to
himself Mobius considers it for a moment
but in the light of Truth Shines on his
shoulders and then he leans back forward
into the shadow to signify him blocking
that notion out of his mind but then as
Mobius says he and Loki's interests are
no longer aligned the overhead lights
shift back upward and as Loki says he's
lying to himself the light behind Mobius
shrinks back down this scene is just a
really cool example of how all the
different elements of the show come
together so well Mobius says to Loki
that Loki doesn't really do Partners
unless it benefits him and he intends to
betray them and Loki responds that quote
it was and means to an end this exchange
is likely about Loki working for Thanos
and it confirms that he was only doing
that as part of his own larger agenda
and branslayer's office she listens to
more theremin music
please
this is La senior or the swan by
composer Camille Sasson played here
again by Clara rockmore who also
performed the Tchaikovsky song that we
heard back in episode two Loki director
Kate Herron features theremin music
throughout the series and that's because
she actually played rockmore's rendition
and her pitch to direct this series Gren
Slayer signs Loki's execution order
using the same FDR high school pin that
Moby has noticed in episode 2 and note
how he looks down at it again here that
pen and its meaning will pay off in the
final episode of the series here
rensslayer tells him you've seen all of
existence same as me so you know
friendship like ours is
well Connor and worth fighting for this
is pure manipulation by her because
later on she orders him pruned without
much of a second thought its
manipulation on a smaller scale than he
remains who puppets multiple people in
timelines we're still not entirely sure
by the end of season one how much
rensslayer knows about everything
including her own past but hopefully
we'll get those answers in season two
B15 is clearly still affected by Sylvie
having been inside her mind and she
stares at this poster which reads did
you get them all verify through deletion
it has this big brothery mustached man
whom we've seen in the credits and I
don't know how anyone could pass by this
creepy propaganda poster every day and
still think they were the good guys she
brings Sylvie back to The Rock's cart
site and Sylvie reconstructs her memory
I looked happy I loved the decision to
not let the audience see what B15 has
seen but instead of just focus on a
reaction as tears mixed with the rain
it's kind of a nod of the famous tears
and Rain monologue from Blade Runner a
major inspiration for Loki cited in one
division with the 10 house or gate sign
the implication behind her saying I
looked happy is of course that she
hasn't been happy at the TBA which means
that maybe all agents could sense that
there was something wrong with this
reality of theirs I've mentioned
Severance before in terms of the
parallels to Loki and this moment
reminds me of when Yul Vazquez tells
Adam Scott's character that even when he
couldn't remember who he was or why he
was sad the sadness was still there B15
asks what now
I love that there's a thundercrack right
after she asks this because there's a
storm coming for the TVA baby and she
knows it movies confirms from
rensslayer's stolen temp pad that she
pruned C20 to cover up the truth and who
could see three dates 11 8 15 37 7 13
1974 and 3 15 2050. the last one is when
The Rock scar disaster took place which
is interesting because March is not
supposed to be hurricane season in the
Gulf Coast but you know what we don't
have category eight and nine hurricanes
either in the Gulf Coast so 2050 is just
gonna be all sorts of messed up 1537 I
assume is that a spot in France that we
saw in episode one oh we know C20 was at
the 1985 Oshkosh Ren Fair 1974 must have
been some other incident that they
visited Mobius tells Loki that he was
right about the TVA from the beginning
and before they go off to take it down
he says
whoever whatever you want to be even
someone good
I mean just in case anyone ever told you
different Loki takes it and grins
because this probably is the first time
someone told him that he actually was in
a place to really hear it and believe it
but then ranslayer has Mobius pruned
Loki's first real true friend and you
see that pain all over Loki's face as
rensslayer leads Loki and Sylvia into
the elevator the timekeepers everything
has this golden yellow glow reminding us
of the golden yellow brick road to The
Wizard of Oz maybe Sophie and ranslayer
have this exchange what was my Nexus
event
I don't remember oof just brutal kind of
reminds me of Don treeper and that
amazing meme in madman that like I want
to tweet at people who yell at me I feel
bad for you
I don't think about you at all and that
little smile from Rensselaer really rubs
salt in the wound at the idea that
Sylvie's warm safe home with her toys
and people who loved her were all ripped
away by someone who didn't even care
enough to have it leave a lasting
impression so we all meet the
timekeepers and all three are actually
voiced by Jonathan majors
[Music]
they walk Ed away
as Sylvie and Boogie fight the hunters
you can see that the timekeeper chamber
is designed with all these stairways
going to Nowhere looking like M.C
escher's relativity lithograph and once
again like when she was little Sylvie
gets won over on rensslayer knocking her
out and beheading the center timekeeper
and the other two laugh creepily before
shutting down even creepier fashion like
malfunctioning Disneyland robots the
timekeepers are revealed for what they
are one of Sam Wilson's bakery that he's
old Bucky were always the villains
causing them trouble The Big Three what
big three Androids aliens and Wizards
but we get the creepiest creep of all
right listen closely you hear the words
you soon being whispered exactly what he
remains final words will be distill me
after she kills him see you soon
Loki gets up the courage to profess his
love to Sylvie but before he can
rensslayer prunes him through the back
just like the way he stabbed Colson in
the back his face is the last thing to
disappear similar to how Vision
disappeared in one Division and Brenda
Lee's if you love me really love me
plays it with the credits and we hear
the lyrics When at last our life on
Earth is through I will share eternity
with you if you love me really love me
let it happen I won't care echoing the
fact that these Loki variants have loved
even through the end of O world and an
apocalypse there is a new photograph
during the credits if you look closely
Sylvie as a young girl and we get our
first post-credits scene of Loki Loki
wakes up in the void and he asks is hell
he's referring to hell with one L which
is the afterlife from Norse mythology
where we got the Christian notion of
h-e-l-l Buddy hears this voice not yet
but you will be unless you come with us
and he sees these three Loki variants
standing over him like the shot of the
Avengers when they were standing over
him to arrest him in the 2012 film here
we get Richard E Grant as classic Loki
wearing the Jack Kirby yellow and green
1962 Comics outfit kid Loki who played a
part in the Young Avengers Comics
alligator Loki who might be a not to
throg or a Thor frog variant from the
comics who will meet in episode 5 and
boastful Loki wielding a hammer similar
to mjolnir but his hammer actually looks
fashioned from a wrench handle and a
piece of a railroad track they are in
what looks like the ruins of New York
City or at least pieces of New York City
that have been pruned here to the void
with a crumbling Avengers Tower in the
background this is a slightly different
Tower than the one that we saw in 2012
because notice it doesn't yet have The
quinjet Landing Pad which got added in
the events of Avengers Age of Ultron we
will actually see in episode 5 that this
is actually King Tower q-e-n-g a tower
linked to Kang Enterprises of Mr Griffin
one of the king variants that we
actually see I think in the quantumania
mid-credit scene actually the song that
we hear here is Alan silvestri's
Avengers score I'll take that drink now
which is what Loki said after they
caught him
I love that drink now okay our
re-breakdown of episode 5 journey into
Mysteries coming next and we went deep
into this void to find even more great
stuff including who we spotted before
throg but we're gonna talk a lot about
him because another deleted scene was
just revealed in previous form showing
Frog and The Voice work that Chris
Hemsworth did for him so be sure to
check out our episode 5 read breakdown
when it drops you can follow me at eavos
follow new rockstars And subscribe to
new rockstars and all three of our
channels of the new rockstars Network
for breakdowns of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
thank you
[Music]